[Applause]
it's like it's weird because it's like
it's like he's it's like he's dead it's
like he's dead pop
put it next to me no no no you no will
he sit up
not really so yeah um
touch his head touch his hand it's so
creepy
yeah that's that's weird oh come on dude
he really is sort of falling apart at
this point but he's been sent down
rivers he got mauled by a bear
like this was all things we did to him
during filming and like really good
though look at the
look at the look at the the eyebrows and
stuff
[Applause]
it's yeah it's strangely horrible i
don't know i don't know what's happening
to it at the end of the press tour so
if anybody you know wants it
[Applause]
maybe not actually giving you enthusiasm
i'll try and speak slowly so that
everyone understands
so we were filming in south africa and
unbeknownst to me the uh some of the
south african crew had been filming
what is known as a sack spider crawling
up and down out of this tree
so the sax spiders in the tree they're
filming it filming each other i've got
footage saying
this is terrifying look how terrifying
that is no one told me
i run out of the uh the building
everything's a secret so i can't tell
you what building i run out of the
building
into the wilderness as this sac spider
just crawled
down you got it down
[Music]
absolutely bricked it and cannot repeat
what i said costume was off
and our first ad the first assistant
director was english
pretty casually they just picked it up
and chucked it as all the south africans
went no no no
and then we found out i could have died
wow
i didn't it didn't even like you google
a sac spider-by it is awful
so that is a better sorry harry is it
ugly you're like he's like got a really
big body
it's got poisonous balls keep going
all right it's making the story a bit
different
different are you so the spider's balls
you're not favorite like kylie minogue
would you go to see this film i'm i'm
beside myself already yeah i couldn't
watch that on my own though
no no well hopefully no one will be
watching it by themselves it'll do very
well
because tom you wouldn't you don't like
these films sorry guys
i'm not a support the film tom
i'm such a worse when it comes to this
kind of thing i would be the worst
horror movie director you could imagine
no but no but that's weird because john
you didn't like these films
no not at all i i think the technical
term is a scaredy cat
i never saw horror movies growing up uh
i was too terrified and
obviously i'm a huge horror fan now if
you saw my itunes list over the last
year you'd say i think we have a problem
um but it's uh it's phenomenal i don't
think i'm my name
is the one that you see and say can't
wait to see a horror movie from that guy
but
the original script came to me and it's
actually uh an incredible story of
family and so it's
to me you can't tell by looking at the
poster we can show that again
but it is a love letter to my kids it's
about what would you do
uh as a parent what extremes would you
go to to protect your kids
and is this true that this film you
originally weren't going to be in
well we had just had our second child
and i was about to do mary poppins and
so i was in a sort of
general feeling of joy i didn't know if
i wanted to go towards the darkness of
the pitch that he'd given me for this
film
and then i i'd mentioned a friend of
mine too john when he pitched me i said
oh you should call so-and-so
and um and so so-and-so is so good
so he did call so-and-so and you didn't
send her the script admittedly she
wasn't sort of hired but um
so close but so good then i read the
script and i was like you need to call
her and fire her
are you still friends with her we are
until the movie comes out and then she's
like
you have dabbled in the dark arts have
you known i have
yeah you did the red hotel yeah
[Applause]
and without any prompting at all this
glass that we all had our fingers on
spelt out knowledge is not free right
none of us were intelligent enough to
have come up with that phrase
let's ask it you know so we asked what
price is knowledge
and it spelt out your life and the glass
shot off the table
i literally just got goosebumps oh
no i i ju i've never done it because
because you've done it haven't you ethan
you know yeah my you're giving some
power to this and i'm i'm liking
that because my sister and i were doing
the ouija board once i was about 12 and
uh my sister asked the ouija board who i
was in my past life
i was on the board i mean technically my
fingers were touching it
and it spelled out james dean
i might have affected it i might have
hated it
i'm not sure but i feel real mad it felt
real can we just say how pleased we are
that bill's here at all because there
was a time when you were dead
that's right what yes
i know i'm looking a lot better now
yeah i know it's right there no well
this is
i'm sure that this is referring to the
fact that uh
i was mistakenly reported as dead
on the bbc website
at the bbc not even like not i know it
was the bbc website
and um it just said uh tributes are
pouring in for actor and comedian
musician bill bailey who has died at the
age of 52 which is really annoying
because
they got the age wrong firstly i was so
annoyed about that
and they used a weird photo as well i
said no is this the photo
i mean what is that i think
that is perfect for an obituary that is
that says that says
this sucks
yeah no that says sad isn't it it's sad
dying
off you go with your story okay so my
fiance is from the czech republic
and um a big big tradition there on
easter monday
and this is fact is the the girls beg to
get whipped
so whoa okay this is right now i've ever
not known
okay i don't know where we got these
people from
i don't know were they veterans
were they vetted
it is like it is like we left the door
open over the weekend
some people just wandered in okay
next one please hello hello
hi what's your name petra petra and
where are you from petra i'm from czech
republic
[Laughter]
true it's true it's true we're begging
to be whipped we don't want to eat
something
no petra they can't no you you don't beg
to be whipped do you petra
i do what's all that about on easter
monday
only on these chimneys it's a tradition
that
um if you get whipped on easter monday
you will remain beautiful and healthy
for the upcoming year
who came up with that one yeah really
probably yeah i think a man came up
yeah really and then you've got a friend
is it a friend of yours who's a psychic
oh god oh yeah this is my favorite bit
it's finding out how one story comes out
and then it obliterates so it's
the defining thing
look yeah i did um meet a psychic who's
a friend of mine and i was seeing her
she's got lots and lots of different
um strings her bones she does healing
and she does
um other things and but she also has a
um a talent for mediumship and as i was
seeing her for something else she said
oh margaret is here does that mean
anything
and i said yes it does and i suddenly
thought well i've got
if i'm saying before you get i've been
asked to play her
i hadn't actually said yes at that point
and uh
i said well yeah no actually if you've
got the horse
you know the horse's mouth it's in the
room you're not gonna say yes no
actually
you know so and so i said um yeah and i
asked i said would you mind if i played
you
and uh she said
no she said well no she did say i think
you're a better idea than the other
actor
oh the other idea the other you know the
other who was the other
they never told me the other the other
possibility but where there was one
sound of a lone gunshot right now
but there are it was a very typically a
typical
margaret thing in this you had met her i
had met her she had a
she had a way yeah a couple of times yes
yeah yeah she's not
but um she had a little way of
sometimes complimenting her and putting
it down at the same time she was
um and the fact that she said yeah i
think you're better than that it was
just like you never knew where you were
with her
then she came through with another note
which was useful whether it came whether
it was
true because the psychic was
fantastically intuitive or there really
was the ghost tomorrow telling me i
don't
i don't know but the note was good and
she said get the smoking right
okay and i smoked in a particular way
and always remember
that the cigarette holder is as much a
weapon for expression as anything else
and that was a good note and she was
somebody who was innately dramatic
if you're royal you can't necessarily
talk much you're a walking icon
you're a walking so she was very she was
very
i think conscious about the silhouette
and whatever
she did with her body and particularly
with her hands and so
you know anyway we asked the audience
about their biggest fears
and uh let's let's just delve amongst
just a warning before you say anything
ruffalo will take you down
okay okay so hands up have you got a if
you've got a fear we ask people
uh what's yours i'm actually afraid of
sperm in places it's not supposed to be
i'm a forensic scientist
you're a forensic scientist yes so but
but where i find it in really weird
places and i feel like it's everywhere
and it freaks me out i think you should
have your couch checked out
[Applause]
things men are not thinking
uh uh oh
okay so what's your name dean okay come
out here dean put your hat down
okay stand up there okay okay let's
bring it let's bring the lights out
let's bring the lights down let's bring
the lights off
you